tous saluent oiseaux et tina quelle
surprise vous avez un nouveau reportage
à faire oui un grand reportage sur l'île
aux enfants c'est une idée à moi parce
que j'avais envie de revenir vous voir
mais c'est gentil ça mais ça va vous
donner beaucoup de travail ont pas mal
mais il suffit de s'organiser j'ai
trouvé un aide alors ça va me simplifier
l'existence
monsieur d'islam non françois pas du
tout casimir
je vais téléphoner nous devons nous
rencontrer si vous l'avez pas vu casimir
eh bien
j'ai pas une bonne idée robin c'est pas
du tout ça que je voulais dire il est
très très serviable donc je n'ai pas vu
aujourd'hui encore pour pas nous nous
affolons pas je vais préparer mon
matériel et je reviens tout de suite
alors si vous le voyez vous les livre ne
m'attends pas si hockey entendu ces
caisses qui m'appelle fait c'est moi
casimir
elle est bien partie la photographe
d'échangés de mort elle se cherche via
la cour après halo mais là elle veut de
voir absolument non non non surtout pas
il ne faut pas qu'elle me trouve si tu
savais ce qu'elle veut me faire faire
elle n'a pas l'air comme ça mais elle
est très méchante nicheurs zoé c'est sa
méthode en si si si apple veut
m'enfermer dans un cabinet noir
occasion
je suis arrivé non pas du tout avec ses
photos
ab je crois j'ai compris tu sûr qu'elle
t'a dit un cabinet noah wyle cabinet
noir cabinet noir ou ou peut-être en
salle à manger noir ou cuisine noir ça
ne serait pas chambre noire par hasard
c'est ça c'est ça comment as-tu de vie
n'est pas parce que quand on fait des
photos olé développés on les tire dans
une chambre noire parce qu'il veut pas
du tout lumière que tu es sur ce thème
alors elle ne me prends pas mal mais au
contraire tu as eu bien de la chance
qu'elle te demande de l'aider moi je
n'ose à attraper vite cet appareil et a
lancé un nouveau tournage d'accord
j'arrive un rique attends attends par
ton dieu me donne un petit sourire
voilà encore
là
j'arrive il n'oublie pas de faire clock
françois je ne cherchais vite j'ai
besoin de toi les critiques craignent un
obstacle au milieu du jardin voilà je
vais en faire un grand reportage photo
sur l'île pour jouer alors prêt en
attendant peut-être temps que je me
coiffe
ça ne bouge plus clic de souris sourit
voilà très bien claquée par un gros plan
dans la vie tu m'as fini mon gâteau amis
bonjour voila je suis épuisée encore une
fois j'avais de gros colis pour monsieur
du score vous invite à vous vous voulez
voir quelque chose c'était pas de refus
mademoiselle julie t mével a un bon
verre de limonade merci merci facteur ne
bougeait plus je vais vous prendre en
photo au milieu de vos amis
attention
parfaite voilà à julie maintenant
bientôt il faut que je le redis 1,8
milliard
tiens casimir voilà un sandwich hoarau
et à la groseille que je t'avais préparé
je n'ai pas d'eau pour jouer là bas je
prendrai plus tard des photos d'abord ça
alors c'est bien la première fois que
casimir n'abandonne pas tous bords et
sandwichs
françois tu veux bien à ranger les
jouets là au fond ça fait un peu
fouillis
les constables enfants oui d'accord
tenez ils sont sans voix lactée rien là
comme ça après oui jean casimir je peux
voir ça ce que m'a dit mon aide ça va
plus être fraîche pour est d'accord bon
alors c'est grave
je prends mon sandwich afrique et
j'avais développé mais font tout dans la
chambre noire
[Musique]
alors
satan
delphine et sonia est ce que vous êtes
déjà allé dans un zoo oui alors savez
vous que le soir dans les eaux les
animaux rêve et savez-vous de coin il
rêve
non alors écoutez cette poésie de michel
butor
attention qu'on commence
à la tombée de la nuit quand se sont
refermées l'écrit
l'éléphant rêve à son grand troupeau le
rhinocéros à des troncs d'arbres
je ne comprends pas ce qui peut
tellement plaire aux finances errance
dans les troncs d'arbres enfin passons
il rêve à ce qu'ils veulent un ils sont
libres alors l'hippopotame rêve adelac
clair la girafe à des frondaisons de
fougères le dromadaire
il revient le dromadaire tu cet animal
qui a plein de bosses partout à des
oasis d'un tente le bison à des océans
d'herbe
dissociant d'air ça c'est sûrement très
beau que tu te rends compte une prairie
verte et grandes qui ressemble à un
océan mais à a tu sais les animaux il
répond si le lion est bien le lion rêve
des craquements dans les feuilles le
tigre de sibérie a des traces sur la
neige l'ours polaire à des cascades
poissonneuse parce qu'il aime bien
poisson ours polaires un tel film la
panthère à des plages passant dans le
rayon de lune le gorille qui a mené
banham rêve à des bananiers croulants de
leurs fleurs violettes les fleurs des
bananiers sont violets que ne saviez pas
elle a des coups de vent dans des
camions du nuage le phoque à des
archipels mouvants de la banquise
disloqué et les enfants du quartier quoi
ils rêvent sonia il vient moi je suis
persuadé que les enfants du gardien et
tous les autres enfants eh bien ils
doivent tous rêvé de l'île aux enfants
tu crois pas si tu rêves pas les deux
enfants
tu rêves à lennon en fuite seront
aussi
non invalidants enfants mais tu rêves
khalil aux enfants qu'une
rage et j'ai hâte de voir les photos de
casimir est et celle de zoé j'espère
qu'ils vont pouvoir faire un bel album
que je montrerai aux enfants et que je
passerai ensuite parmi les plus beaux
livres et peut-être qu'avec les superbes
paysages de l'île on va pouvoir faire
des photos que tous les facteurs du
monde
distribueront à tous les enfants du
monde pas vrai quel beau un patient
malade oui
les enfants que je
suis liquidés a fait marcher toute la
journée sur l'île de long en large
soutien qu une bouffe et qu'avez vous
photographier un peu de tout des
paysages j'ai les photos qui sont en
train de sécher je voulais montrera tout
à l'heure et vous en être contente un
train a
préféré il avait chargé des portraits
attention ce sont des chefs-d'oeuvre
voici julie et ses bonbons
l'infarctus et son verre de limonade
ça c'est avec françois et ses petits
gâteaux
à part ça c'est mon sandwich de sa gamme
j'ai compris tu les a tout loupé c est
absolument pas aussi vous m'avez demandé
de rendre ce qu'il y avait en chacun
d'un plus représentatif à casimir je
crois que j'ai compris zoé voulez parler
du caractère de chacun d'entre nous par
exemple tu aurais dû photographier le
facteur qui toujours très gai en train
de chanter rapporte une eau bien julie
qui est un petit peu brouillon en train
de tout chercheuse qu'elle a perdu tu es
très aimable allez ça va je les routes
faire ces photos en attendant il ya plus
qu a ajouté 16 points mais pas du tout
de leur n'est pas question non elles
n'ont aucun intérêt pas séparément
peut-être mais tous ensemble avec les
bonnes choses à manger qui lie à dessus
je vais les découper ça fera un
excellent gloubiboulga
calaisis